that's pretty badass though that what he
did I would high-five my grandpa if he
did that if I didn't see him for a long
time he's like yo I'd shrinky
I love Christmas I hate like when
Christmas music starts playing I travel
back home and spend time with my family
during the holidays talking about what
you did throughout the year talking
about what you didn't do and how you're
a failure I usually spend it with my
family but not this year is this gonna
make me cry okay so his daughter just
called he said/she said they're not
coming home for Christmas
lonely grandpa that's all no and it's
not all oh the picture of Gramps
oh no he died did he trick his family
that he died what's up what a clever old
man surprise this would have been a good
like yes Skype commercial that was an
emotional rollercoaster for sure I feel
I feel like you can make a heartwarming
Christmas commercials without faking
someone's death I wasn't ready for that
field trip why couldn't they just fly
him to them like maybe have like a real
conversation with your kids you know
maybe don't just be like I guess I'll
just fake my own death he had a right to
trick them because they were being
shitty kids and look how happy that
family was like at the end of the
commercial I would be so pissed this is
the girl that hates Christmas music they
have a family what the problem I don't
know what his problem is right he must
be oh my god do you think I didn't want
to say I just think about that moment
where all the ad execs were sitting in a
room going oh I know I kind of want to
call my grandma right now I don't have
the time and the money to get there and
now I feel guilty I feel like I should
make the time I do want to spend time
with my family after watching it but
it's just at what cost
he's lucky he didn't get shot
he's lucky one of the kids didn't see
him be like a ghost